so I'll just jump in to start this talk
I want to dispel the the myth of the
lone genius so behind many innovations
there's a story of collective
participation and invention the stories
that never get told Nikola Tesla was not
the only inventor of his time he
competed with Edison both of them had
big teams of people working with them to
sort of investigate radio technology the
same is true in art and culture avatar
was not the sole creation of James
Cameron in fact nearly 3000 people
worked on this film and there's many
examples like this in science and art
where groups of people come together to
create something greater than any one
person could and I don't think any of us
would ever believe that James Cameron
was the only person working on this but
I think it's the the what's happening
right now online and through through
different technologies that allow people
to come together at scale through
technology that brings the idea of how
we can assemble lots of people together
solving problems into a fresh focus so
we know about Wikipedia and millions of
people working together to produce the
largest cheapest encyclopedia galaxies
were science fans categorize different
images or the Foldit project where
gamers get in into folding proteins and
coming up with unique combinations that
actually inform laboratory science and
these are all very clever ways to
motivate small contributions from many
people that in aggregate lead to
something really great but the question
that interests me is how can we harness
this collective effort energy and
intelligence to innovate on problems
facing society and so can we take that
that social networking crowdsourcing
sort of organizational dynamic
organizational those processes and point
them at problems that that we need to
solve
so to help frame the
seneschal of this idea I'm going to
share a personal experience I had a
couple years back I was at a conference
called Chi but you guys probably know
about Chi right chi it's a large
multitrack conference 3,000 people or so
attend every year and I was sitting in a
talk where it was totally crowded people
were spilling out into the hallway
sitting in the aisle ways and there are
rooms right down the hall where the room
could the the talk could have been
shuffled in over there and you know a
much larger room that had lots of empty
seats could have shifted over to this
room and the organizers didn't do
anything wrong per se they just didn't
know ahead of time what was going to be
popular what did people want to go see
so I got really interested in this
problem and got to go observe the
planning process for the conference and
took note of how tangible this process
was and collaborative basically they had
a big wall of paper and each little
squares of sessioned and each tiny
little piece of pink or blue or green
paper as a paper that just got accepted
to the conference and they would do this
right after the PC the paper committee
decided what papers got into the
conference and so this massive
scheduling task that they had to do 16
parallel tracks over four days and what
they created was flawed in many ways
they had no information they recorded no
information about how papers related
outside of their particular session and
they had again no information about what
was going to be popular of course at the
conference but what would happen is they
would make this preliminary schedule and
then weeks later someone would email
them and say hey I can't make it on
Monday or you know you scheduled my I
just want to make sure you don't
schedule my my talk here at the same
time as another talk that I have and so
all these constraints started to come up
from the community and because they have
no information if they want to make a
swap to another place
it's bound to cause other problems for
other people so anyone solution could
make disruptions unknown consequences of
making a swap to some other part of the
schedule scheduling in many ways is a
wicked problem and I mean that both kind
of informally and in a formal sense and
riddle and Webber coined this term
wicked problem to refer to problems that
are so interconnected due to social
political economic factors that any one
solution that satisfies one stakeholder
is bound to create a problem for another
stakeholder it's an a woven system of
problems if you will and they went on to
define wicked problems as ones that have
no writer on solutions they only differ
in their degree of goodness or badness
their problems where different
stakeholders often have different views
on the on how to frame the problem so
they have different worldviews and and
that causes them to think about the
problem differently the constraints of
the problem change over time and the
problem really is never solved
and so conference scheduling and
scheduling perhaps more generally may
not be as wicked as some of the
political socio technical challenges
that would riddle and Weber we're
talking about but it's certainly
complicated by different points of view
and by hidden information information
that's going on in the community that
never reached the level of the planners
the people at the top who are supposed
to be creating this events designing
this experience for 3,000 people and and
so this is where I came in and found
some great collaborators and Lydia and
in how cheese Zhang and Rob Miller and
juco kam and Paul Andre to create a
system that would tap into that
information embedded in the community we
created a series of interfaces where we
can engage
the different populations of people and
so in the first stage right after the
program committee decided what papers
got into the conference we would engage
them in a basically a digital paper
sorting method where we could get
affinity information how papers relate
to each other
and it was just a simple dragging
solutions on to a pane and then deciding
what you think makes a good session and
then if you get enough people doing that
you start to realize what the
relationships are between papers to
further refine that we took that
affinity information and gave it and use
it to pick a top ten list of papers that
relate to the particular author's paper
so the author is actually the one who
knows best whether other papers relate
to their own and so we ask them you know
is this okay in your session not okay in
your session is this a paper that you
would like to attend if you had the
choice and then we took all that
information and set it into this
scheduling tool that the organizers
could use to see all those constraints
and preferences from the community and
then to solve some of the the hard and
soft constraints that are necessarily in
conflict but it suggests different swaps
that could be made and so finally the
nice thing about doing that is now we
have all this data about how each paper
in the conference relates to each other
so we can feed that information into a
mobile app so this is a tool called
confer created by a knot and David
Karger at MIT to allow attendees to go
and like the papers they want to see and
then because we've got all this
information about hot papers relate it
immediately starts providing useful
recommendations and doesn't suffer from
the bootstrapping problem of the first
few people not having recommendations
for them so we turn this process into
this digital process essentially we've
transformed this messy paper-based
process
to a digital process we took a process
that normally takes months because of
all the emails and and back-and-forth
people have to do and the wrangling of
the schedule and really worked it into
kind of an afternoon of intensive
planning and this was the process used
by two of our main conferences for a few
years I think they've fallen back to
using spreadsheets and undergrads which
i think is a larger challenge of sort of
research software getting adopted into a
volunteer community that it it's hard to
pass things on from year to year but you
can find out more about this project
that project Toby and so coming back to
this question of collective innovation
the hypothesis here is that we can
harness the collective energy and
intelligence and creativity of people
and solve bigger problems but we're not
just going to throw a bunch of people
into a into a forum and see what comes
out you know we don't want to have the
too many cooks in the kitchen problem
what we're focused on is how do we
create fairly confined and well
structured interactions for people to
contribute in many different ways and to
coordinate those and so the question
that really interests me is how can we
scale out design practices and one
approach is to teach a lot of people how
to do design and I think that's that's
an approach that they advocate in the
d.school
here it's an approach that my colleagues
got clemmer has really thought a lot
about in terms of scaling up and
teaching many many learners our tact is
a little bit different in that I'm
really interested in how do we bring
lots of people together to solve a
problem together and we're looking at a
number of strategies where people are
collaboratively looking at the these
wicked problems
so this notion of a system of
constraints that's something we saw in
the COBE project right this idea that
part of a solution notion of collective
innovation is to figure out what the
community needs and and sort of tap into
all the things that people think about
and sort of prefer in coming up and
shaping a solution for that community
this notion was actually a concern that
riddle and Weber talked about going back
to the wicked problem idea they actually
talked about how is the designers job to
identify constraints within the context
that they're trying to solve and you
know of course if you don't have any
constraints it's just a blank canvas
that often is not enough to get help you
kind of move in a direction that's or
the opposite problem is that you have no
constraints and you're left to wander
everywhere but what they were really
concerned about is this notion of a
tightly constrained space where you go
out and you need fine and you learn
about all the problems and you know if
they're not to constraint you can use
optimization you know the operational
researchers would be able to formulate a
mathematical function to be able to
solve this problem designers don't quite
think about it in such mathematical
terms but what they talked about was
that in many wicked problems those
constraints are so tight and have
collapsed so much that there are
literally no solutions that that would
solve that problem for all the
stakeholders and and so interestingly
one of riddles former students riddle
was a professor at Berkeley in the urban
planning department and one of his
students Jeff Nickerson told me that
riddle would teaches students not to
abide by the constraints they would
teach them to push back against the
constraints and would teach these
exercises where you would evaluate each
constraint and then try to figure out
how you could go back to that
stakeholder or flip it on it on the
other
and and and push it back so that we
could finally carve out a potential
solution designers would understand that
constraints are socially constructed you
know these are constraints put on by
other people preferences desires needs
and that likewise they could be
deconstructed they could be taken back
and so I think a key technology or
strategy under that idea of collective
innovation is how can we use technology
to discover constraints ahead of time as
much as possible all right to discover
them throughout an ongoing process of
need finding and understanding a problem
and in the case of scheduling a large
conference it's really important to
understand those ahead of time because
the event only happens once and you your
your planning or your design of the
schedule needs to happen ahead of time
but in the case of other design settings
we can structure it around getting
feedback so you can have proposals for
solutions and then get input from your
stakeholders on the other side
and so you know this is partly why a
studio crit environment has become such
a standard practice in design and
project-based learning because it's one
of the key mechanisms for how people
learn in a very open-ended
problem-solving setting when there are
no right or wrong solutions and that
requires sort of input from lots of
different people to help understand in a
very fluid way not like the mathematical
operational research way but in a very
fluid way what sort of concerns people
have and so a key question that drove
our research here was how can we scale
up feedback practices make them easier
for people to get feedback make it fast
to get feedback and to get a diverse
representative pool of feedback
providers and so I started giving my
students in my design courses
assignments where they would come up
with ideas and then throw them up
the web kind of like a giant sounding
board so for example students in my
startup studio class would create
storyboards and then they put the
storyboards we still do this now we put
the storyboards up on Google Forms and
go out and recruits you know feedback
providers hopefully not just your
friends but people who are involved in
the problem that you're trying to solve
and see what ideas resonate with people
there's this concept that an in day and
John Zimmerman other folks at CMU
invented called speed-dating whereas a
paper-based sort of feedback process
where you cycle through a bunch of ideas
like storyboards so we kind of took that
idea and thought about how you do that
online and feedback providers would
either write text to respond or they
would leave a video the use of video
based feedback was leading us to capture
some of the more nuanced emotional
reactions to ideas but the intuition
here pedagogically is that we're trying
to get students out of the classroom
we're trying to get students to look
beyond the traditional boundaries of the
classroom as a place for getting
feedback from your peer from your
instructor and to go to the client go to
the customer go to the user who's going
to be affected by these design ideas
include taking that concept a step
further what we had students do is as a
early stage design activity create a
homepage for their new startup their new
app idea and that's all they've done so
far they there's no app that has been
developed all they've done is created a
simple web page and then we teach them
and give them a little bit of money to
go out and advertise their startup and
so they're learning about SEO search
engine optimization they're playing
around with Google Analytics and AdWords
and what they're trying to find out is
is anyone searching on those terms and
interested enough in the web ad that you
put up there that they're going to click
on it and go find out if they can get
that app is there a need out there can
you can you measure some sort of need
that exists the other kind of nifty
thing you can do is you can a be test
while you're there so you put an ad up
there and then you can randomly send
people to two variations of your nascent
app idea and see if there's certain
branding that appeals to somebody it
appeals to people more or even test two
different concepts and of course you get
a lot of data from this and you can
while maybe not statistically
significant you can use the data to
drive decisions and really teach the
students about the data-driven design
world all before building an actual
prototype so another project my former
postdoc Kurt Luthor tried to meet this
demand for feedback by creating a tool
that would generate feedback at demand
on scale and he called a crowd crit and
designers could submit a design idea and
then it would recruit people online to
provide feedback and one of the key
features in this tool is that it would
take principles of the design domain in
this case it was visual design and try
to embed it in the tool and so that
feedback providers regardless of their
level of expertise would have a very
structured process for how to provide
good feedback in this domain and so you
can see here's a poster for concert and
the feedback provider could go through
and look at these kind of pre authored
statements that one could apply to the
design and then they could adapt them if
they wanted to as well as put
annotations on the design so it's very
much designed for visual graphical
designs but it could also I think apply
to product design to any sort of
representation that you can throw up on
the web and have people look at I think
the same conceptual principle still
would work here and then after you get a
bunch of feedback from different
stakeholders we provided a visualization
where you could go and
look at the kind of different feedback
that you have positive and negative you
could click in and see more details you
could look at who is providing the
feedback and really get a sense of the
different different reactions to your
design ideas and so our work is not only
developing these novel interfaces it's
trying to evaluate them and run studies
through these systems and so we've been
running numerous experiments on factors
related to scale to structuring
critiques to the social dynamics that
emerge during feedback exchange one of
the early things that we learned was
that the number of feedback providers
lead designers to identify a larger
number of issues so as you add more
feedback providers you get closer and
closer to what experts would see in a
design it does have some diminishing
return but there's some some claim at
least that where the scale and diversity
of networks of people whether it's crowd
sourcing or community provide value for
feedback exchange we also collected data
on the benefits of using these
scaffolded rubrics James know like maybe
what asymptotes faster in terms of Fundy
here's the tricky part about evaluating
feedback is you either have the just the
opinion of the feedback receiver which
is what I was about to show what we
measured was how the feedback receiver
valued the feedback or you have to
measure the impact of that feedback on
subsequent designs and then measure the
pre post affected the before and after
design and we tried many variations of
this and it's really really hard correct
so like here what I was going to explain
is we had people rate the feedback how
helpful was it on a scale from one his
hand and what this data shows is that
experts are generally better at
providing feedback the novices
if you give the experts of rubric they
don't really benefit from that but if
you give novices this rubric they
increase rating the ratings of their
feedback they provide increase so if you
want data there's some here's some data
that structure actually in the rubric
actually helps provide better feedback
as judged by a novice and by by experts
experts had the same the person
receiving it
I think the person receiving is is the
most important actually we can discuss
that a bit we also measured it from an
instructor's perspective which also
backed us up but I actually think it's
the receiver that's a more important
opinion a judge of this because they're
the ones that have to integrate that
feedback understand what it means
they're the ones that determine how
helpful it is but it's a very different
question of is it actually more helpful
and like I said we've been exploring
that and try different things and this
is a project actually with Manish and
Bjorn Hartman from Berkeley and we tried
many studies like this and it was it was
fun but we definitely learned some
things about rubrics one of the things
that we did was a follow up linguistic
analysis what was in that feedback that
was powerful there that was resonating
what were the patterns in the feedback
and so our analysis showed that features
that correlated highly with high ratings
by the receivers of the feedback were
things like obvious things like okay the
longer the feedback the better was rated
but also more emotional words being used
more specificity in the words that were
used rather than vague higher-level
terms and using more of a suggestion
approach like giving people
action-oriented feedback was was
preferred and the rubrics helped to
increase those types of features
so shifting from feedback from this
online exchange platform to an in-class
inks in a physical setting that that
sort of sighting that we have here my
PhD shoots student Amy Shannon from CMU
is very interested in how to how to take
advantage of the fact that in many North
American classrooms at least most people
have some sort of device on them I see a
lot of people with paper that's good and
not too many people with their laptops
open but everyone probably has at least
this on them and so can we take
advantage of that to make the classroom
more interactive to make it a much more
participatory setting and so peer
presents encourages students to
collaboratively comment when a peer is
up presenting their their ideas and so
instead of having somebody in the back
of the classroom who doesn't get to
raise their hand whether it's due to
time or shyness we can still capture
their their point of view and the tool
offers some nice features in terms of
how do you get fast feedback and to do
that feedback exchange in a short amount
of time and how to how to prep the the
students who so how to get the students
who are about to present to articulate
what they want feedback on ahead of time
so that when they go and do that
feedback exchange its most valuable for
them so I think there's a lot of
potential here not just in feedback
exchange but in terms of when you have a
captive audience in a room together what
are the different learning activities or
collective innovation activities that we
can do together to work on difficult
problems so I think we've made pretty
good progress on this idea of rapid
feedback from diverse stakeholders but
there's still a lot to learn about how
we can better support designers to
interpret and reflect on feed
especially when we have a lot of
conflicting points of view which is what
we learned is another thing we get when
we go at a scale how things like social
capital and self-efficacy affect
feedback exchange and so kind of taking
a step back at this point I love this
conceptual model for design first
introduced by Paul LaSalle he explained
how designers move through these phases
of elaborating on a problem and then
reducing the number of possible outcomes
and it's a really powerful way of
thinking about a design processes having
both a convergent stage in a divergent
stage and you can see it and many of the
you know exercises that we teach into
design classes and I do for example has
adopted this at D School as disolved
adopted this notion at least
conceptually that's sort of the thinking
behind it but when folks like LaSalle in
Buxton were thinking about this it was
mostly thinking about individuals or
small teams of people and but I also
find it very useful in thinking about
how groups of people larger groups of
people can come together to look at
problems so for example I think the COBE
project was a good example of expanding
the possibilities expanding the notion
of expanding at least the information
that we have available for understanding
the problem it's sort of a discovery
process online feedback is a process of
converging because you've got some
options on the table and you're trying
to refine those who trying to choose
maybe between different options a
natural place to also think about how to
apply this model is in the space of
generating ideas and so essentially
brainstorming at scale the idea
brainstorming has been around since the
1940s but as soon as computers came
around folks we're talking about
electronic brainstorming and how can we
how can we get people to brainstorm at a
you know at a terminal this is a from a
very early paper 1992 but the the kind
of long-standing lab result that a lot
of these early electronic brainstorming
studies show is that when you have
people in a room together brainstorming
they get slowed down by each other they
produce fewer ideas than if you have
people generate ideas independently
working by themselves and so that's
that's a result that's been replicated
lots and lots that the the number of
unique ideas increases when as your
group size increases if you have some
sort of electronic medium that allows
people to generate ideas in parallel and
if you have a traditional brainstorming
setting group size you know kind of you
Plateau you don't get any more ideas
or more unique ideas when you increase
the number of people of course
Stanford's Bob Hutton and Andrew
hargadon make the connection observation
that there's other reasons why you
brainstorm besides just coming up with
lots of unique ideas teams you know bond
they get to know each other superpowers
there's good reasons for why you still
want to do this in person physical
brainstorming yet we're still seeing a
resurgence of this idea of electronic
brainstorming what's referred to today
as collaborative ideation and so you see
systems like open I do that engages
people interested in social innovation
challenges participatory budgeting
projects like the city of Cambridge who
got their residents to generate ideas
for how to spend the budget question I
was under the impression all along that
if you would have people working alone
because ideas anything that stuck in
there online button if you're working in
a group you see someone else I do you
can build out this down so their work
attendance to not get stuck and I
experienced that myself also when I was
brainstorming with my group that's
helped a bit of what you just said I
wondering if you had what was their
initial hypotheses and white why am I
not you're absolutely right yeah sure
let's telling the story here building up
to it but you're right if if we just
believe that result and decided okay
we're all going to we're never going to
meet together in person and get inspired
from each other then that would be
pretty boring world to live in and we're
not talking been talking about the
goodness of these ideas we're talking
about the uniqueness of the ideas but
there is something about you know
independently coming up with things so
that you you don't let things like
groupthink take over the conversation or
being fixated on an idea because it
seems like a good one so there's some
value I think in at least at some point
in the in the process having people
independently think about the problem
because we all have something going on
up here if we can capture that first and
then bring in the social aspect and my
point about systems like this is that
it's clearly exposing you to other
people's ideas you see them in lists
when you go to visit the site so it's
not as social as a physical brainstorm
but you're being exposed to other
people's ideas and and actually that's
kind of my point here is that a lot of
these systems while they do expose
people to others ideas what comes out
tends to be a lot of repetitive ideas
and a lot of very mundane ideas if it's
something about how these ideas are just
kind of listed out and people can borrow
from them or being exposed to mundane
and repetitive ideas kind of then leads
to more redundant and mundane ideas
so to try to combat that my postdoc
Joelle Chan created an interface where
people could all generate ideas in
parallel and then at some point we would
take all those ideas and surface them
into a dashboard interface that a expert
could use to provide inspiration and the
source of in the form of like other
examples that are good or schemas that
seem useful or other ways of thinking
about the problem they would be watching
the space of ideas emerge and then
coming up with ways of facilitating it
on the fly in real time and we found
that they did lead to more creative
ideas the challenge here was how to
scale it so the expert was good at
facilitating maybe tens of parallel ID
aters but when it gets to be much more
than that it's really hard to keep track
of all the different directions that the
brainstorm is going and to be able to
really personalize it for the different
people generating ideas and so how do we
scale us to like hundreds or thousands
of people generating ideas and so to
build on this insight to think about
this problem we started with the insight
that designers often arrange their ideas
spatially like on a whiteboard once you
have a bunch of ideas you start to
cluster them make those affinity
relationships between ideas and so how
we started this was thinking about how
to scale this up too and build it
basically a computational model of all
the ideas that are emerging and this was
work that I was doing with POW singular
Lou and Kristoff gaius at Harvard
actually just got back from Pao's
dissertation defense on Monday she did a
great job and so the idea here was well
what if we can watch how each individual
brainstorm er generates ideas and then
places them within their local pain
their own workspace and see how they
arrange ideas and then also occasionally
throw in other people's ideas that they
can arrange alongside their own and then
from all that relationship all those
relationships build a sparse similarity
matrix between the between the ideas
it's actually very similar to what we
were doing with the Cobie project trying
to determine how papers relate how do
these ideas relate and we we then use
that to create a low dimensional map an
idea map that sort of gives us a simple
represent representation of how all the
ideas relate this is sort of the
experience of the user in the scenario
they are generating their own ideas and
occasionally they they get other ideas
thrown into the mix and they can kind of
arrange them in their own space and then
conceptually what we can do with this
computational model is then sample that
space for either very similar ideas or
very diverse ideas we can be deliberate
about how we want to inspire people to
explore the problem space maybe we want
to there's a rare idea up here that we
want people to go and populate with with
near variants of it one of the studies
we did found that people who saw these
automatically generated diverse examples
tended to generate more diverse ideas
and so it's this idea of can we as we as
we're working together to generate ideas
also synthesize them part of it is we
need to get there anyway to be able to
create some sort of overview of the
space and to better understand what the
best possibilities are but also we can
take those take that computational model
and use it to kind of feed back into the
system to to help inspire people as
they're going along so the very kind of
geeky algorithmic way of thinking about
the problem and I think there's a lot of
there's a social dimension here that
that somewhat gets lost and that's sort
of where I'm interested in exploring now
is
to bring in real social networks of
people that know each other and and who
have some notion of how the how smart
the other persons are what expertise the
other people have and in accounting for
what solutions you want to show to other
people but it's I think it's a fun
research angle and there's a lot of
directions to continue to explore this
so what we've been learning about
collective innovation I think there's a
couple of things that we we do sort of
principles that are starting to emerge
or strategies that seem to work well
discovering constraints and preferences
at scale obtaining feedback from
multiple stakeholders exploring many
solution paths in parallel and also then
generating and synthesizing those ideas
into into you know making sense of at
scale the complex information that's
necessarily part of these wicked
problems also thinking a lot about how
once you get down to it and you're
trying to maybe put a solution out there
for many users you have to make a
decision is there a process by which you
can facilitate a large group of people
to make a rational decision not just
voting but a stage voting process and
I'm coming to understand different
notions of the meaning of collective
whether it's an existing community of
people like the academic community or a
crowd that you can just dial up on the
internet or collaboration between teams
of people I think this this scenario of
people meeting physically in a space and
the fact that they all have some
technology with them provides new
opportunities for how we can get people
solving problems together and I worry
about the scenario of people just
shouting at each other like we've seen
that the town halls recently of people
with their their signs they have like
red
sheet of paper you know disagree and
green I agree and there's just yelling
at each other but I think there's
opportunities here as designers of tools
that help people solve problems together
to do better and so I'm pretty excited
and serious about the idea of applying
these strategies to problems in our
civics and right now what working on is
is thinking about this combination of
design thinking crowdsourcing decision
making and how it might apply itself to
big social problems in a city and we
just started this organization called D
for SD it's a public engagement platform
that seeks to gather different citizens
perspectives on problems and and
applying the design approach to these
problems and we've been working on this
with a bunch of I was explaining at
lunch like we have an army of undergrads
who have gone out like tentacles to
understand owed research this one civic
challenge and this year we're looking at
mobility just going on in discovering
people's stories about problems with
public transit or with traffic and not
just to carve out their own one little
solution but to think about the murad of
problems within that challenge and just
start making connections across those
problems and to of course then to
eventually generate ideas we're actually
still in the need finding stage and
trying to keep everyone going out and
investigating and but staying aware of
all the things that other people are
finding it's a big coordination problem
and Claire have a lot of things I could
talk about with this I think it's a
really fun challenge to think about how
to eventually get this you know citizens
residents engage in this process right
now we mostly focused on having
undergrads because they're they're a
source of that intelligence and energy
that's ready to jump in and participate
but I think there's
a possibility to get people in from out
you know from the city as well and I'd
love to hear any ideas that you guys
have on on how we can do that better and
of course I'm inspired by the work
that's going on at Stanford and Michael
Bernstein is a colleague and a
competitor in the space but I wish he
was here to debate this stuff with but
that's basically my talk and thank you
love to start a conversation yes sir
Lunger last point uh there's a young
instructor here at Stanford who's
working has been working with the city
of San Jose on similar issues and they
used approach that I worked on called
mess mapping which has to be with
addressing wicked problems which I've
used with County and larger communities
over the world you might like it in
touch with him and such based on
different ways of thing I remember is
okay I'll give you this name hey good
good okay oh so you had it earlier like
something about like it's a school that
was like he allowed people to use
there's like laptops and stuff to engage
with like the question right
um and so score sleep is also other like
problems if they go to my teach in the
classroom right I'm for seeing like
people iPad multitaskers
we usually get distracted a play we
click did like the benefit and that's
like outweighing the the eruption well I
think it is it is depends it depends and
I think it takes a bit of it takes the
instructor understanding that there's
going to be that other distractor that a
tendency of people to get sucked into
their Facebook or whatever and
and so there has to be a bit of
mediation around the physical setting
maybe it's TAS walking around and making
sure people are actually participating
but I think look enlarge people like it
a lot especially the people receiving
feedback in fact I I did this thing the
first two assignments this quarter and
then the third assignment students were
asking why we weren't doing it because I
wanted to try it without it and in this
third assignment they were doing like
role plays in the front of the classroom
so I thought the laptops would be
getting in the way but they were
actually like well we really liked being
able to do that so I think I think it
does depend I do think there's a sort of
a design challenge with technology when
you have a laptop even if you're just
working in a team I experienced this a
lot where I get annoyed when someone's
looking at their computer and I'm like
trying to talk to them but it's not that
they're ignoring me necessarily it's
just it's communicated as they're
ignoring me and tablets help out in a
little bit help out a bit because you
can set on the table and you can see
what they're looking at and see if it's
related to what you're even talking
about but so I think there's kind of a
fun technology challenge there and
designing to better facilitate social
interactions while still doing work
together I do I've also had the
experience where we're sitting around
the laptop and you know everybody's
tuned in and you know everybody's
working on the same thing and that
there's there's really something
powerful like even if you're just in a
Google Doc and you know everyone's doing
their part the fluidity of being able to
have verbal conversation and also the
gesture and nonverbal interaction
together with the technology I think
there is a direction there that we
should keep investigating and improving
Lydia this is really exciting
um what are the sort of magic
ingredients I saw her which was rubrics
and vivid in a couple different solution
so my broad question is like why you
think those work so well and I'll
preface that by saying although I do
believe them that what they do in this
bad case where I have to re-engineer my
thoughts to back fit the room trick oh
hey it's playing that part a little bit
well so when I grade students on the
rubric I know this is bad how do I come
to your folks how does that yeah because
sometimes it looks most usually the
process what you want to get rid help
well I have to say I haven't looked at
this assessment I think that's an
important distinction I didn't look at
assessment I looked at feedback very
formative informal helped me shape my
design idea rather than trying to
actually judge it and so I I don't know
I agree I in a personal experience yeah
I tried to justify grades in a backwards
way like you suggest but why do rubrics
work much like a good task description
on crowdsourcing focuses people on the
thing that you actually want them to do
and and embodies what the the wisdom
that has been sort of harvested in a
domain and tries to boil it down to its
essence and then communicates that very
very clearly I think there's an art to
it how to do it right I think it's
taking it yet basically it's taking the
wisdom of domain and trying to bring it
down to its essence so that you can use
that as a way of structuring how to do a
task a very particular task of providing
feedback I think that's essentially how
it how it works by us or introducing
creativity like a new test check into
this verb because the the receivers of
the feedback say that that is a better
serve
doodle-oo if the things that is better
not an to implementing India and you see
the effects of the actual customers yeah
I mean go talk to what James was asking
about I we tried with the crowd Curt
study to measure whether the feedback
that they received actually led to
better visual designs and we found no
significant difference however you got
to keep in mind that we're measuring the
difference between a first version of a
poster and a second version of the
poster and we're trying to see if these
folks over here in this other condition
their improvements were their
improvements you know significantly
better than so I think as from a from a
scientific standpoint we need better bet
better ways of kind of exploring that
better basically paradigms experimental
paradigms to be able to look at the more
subtle things that could be affecting
that exchange yeah it's not a straight
as greening undulating I think the
result I think immediately step there we
have to do right interpretation rules
absolutely yeah and I'm so Amy Shannon
school has it has a nice interaction
once you have all the feedback for how
do you sort it what things are you going
to try to address now try to address
later what things you're going to ignore
I think that anecdotally I talk about
how people as they learn to become
designers actually transition from a
place where they don't want to share
their works like they're not ready to
get feedback they're they have a lot of
social inhibition to getting feedback to
a place where they can then feel more
comfortable getting feedback to a place
where they can then provide feedback for
other people to a place where they crave
getting feedback and they feel like it's
really important to get feedback to I
think at an expert level knowing that
you don't have to get feedback on
everything that you can you can sort of
simulate what your users are going to
think and you can project forward to
some extent so you
have to waste resources getting feedback
there's a social capital of that
exchange especially when you go to your
instructors and ask them for feedback
you can't do that every hour they're
going to ignore you at some point going
back to that point of rubrics and
especially what's that about experts
mean you'll accumulate that I feel like
if you're if you're measuring the impact
of kind of feedback once you give people
such a good Rubik and you think that is
a good rule because it is reducing the
energy field don't you also need to
check if just giving people the release
itself check themselves with like
nursing foundation like a checklist
pretty same exact so we actually did
that say it was a paper called Shepherd
in the crowd and in fact doing the
self-evaluation with the rubric led to
just as as good a performance as having
an external person provided feedback and
that was in a crowdsourcing context and
then and I don't know if the same thing
would be true in a design setting but I
think it also makes that point that I
was just making that a lot largely
depends on the individual how they
interpret it how they emotionally react
to it how how much knowledge they have
to really make sense of it and to figure
out how to act on it I have this great
video so I used to be a postdoc here I
did I did a basically Lydia's job when I
was here and I did these studies in the
basement down the hall where people
would come in and do design studies
where we had them make a design visual
add design so stuff like this where they
produced a lot of different visual
designs like see Wendy back there she
was the one of the really the founder of
ambidextrous magazine yes we use
ambidextrous as a client for one of
these studies and
one of the things that we realized in
sort of providing feedback on their
visual designs of participants is they
would they would emotionally react and
so here's just an example actually I
don't the audio in there but see how
[Music]
funny that I have the CMU thing in the
corner and this was done at Stanford and
now I'm at UCSD anyway so a lot of I
think I've been recognizing for a while
that a lot of it does come down to how
individuals bring information and sort
of to me it's it's this layered thing
it's we are studying the individual but
we're also trying to think about how
those individual effects can be put
together at a scale to like get to a
better place and so we're looking at
team formation I think as a key
component of this you have a big people
big group of people who want to
participate in in solving a problem can
we figure out the best ways to kind of
put them together and to support their
team effort and then it gets down to
like the group level somewhere between
individual and and scale yeah I think
this is one of the things that makes
design so hard is that that person are
teaching it yeah well it doing it
teaching and all those things and I
don't think that's ahsoka humans are
emotional like no because like the
reason you push this idea is you have to
get a little invested in it even if it's
paper on this backtracking and sort of
my AI way I conceptualize it it's just
hard it takes time and I wonder if you
think this is something that we can
address whether the oven when she
thought about tackling this specifically
so
the emotional reaction to it yeah I
don't know what the technology solution
is but I come to deal with its in my
classes and it's and it's you know it's
coaching I think is what it is it's that
helping people realize that first that
feedback is important we can do that
through experimental evidence we can do
that eventually through kind of showcase
studies and we can you know how people
kind of learn it by feeling it and
getting good feedback but then it's also
you know teaching them that you can
invest in the process and the goal that
you're trying to solve a problem but not
into a particular solution so variation
on this on this work that we did was
really focused on how do we get people
to distribute their investments across
multiple ideas in parallel because if
you are invested in one idea and you get
that you can't eked on that and you're
going to react like this guy but if
you've got at least a couple of ideas on
the table and you get critiqued on one
of them you have another one or you know
people can start commenting on how you
can combine the best elements of them
the emotional angle is is the emotion of
the negative emotional reaction is
dulled to some extent it has a lot of
other benefits to in terms of comparing
and contrasting and being able to see if
the Matic trajectory of your designs in
a way that a single design doesn't allow
that question I stood on that because
feeling well the college campuses but
usually you teach students to design
process at the same time as you teach
them the mechanics of visual design into
all aspect and I probably especially for
myself what I got over learning that is
the tool to be much faster dit just
their motion investment is like a
specific design I'm so much smaller know
the emotional aspects because trying to
adjust whether like the plate yawns to
be hard right yeah yeah and you know
professional designer is quick to throw
out ideas if they quick you know in
there there I'm always teaching my
students too
this is a key point is to figure out
what's the biggest risk or the biggest
assumption behind your IDE
yeah and then devise a prototype or an
experiment or a user study to test that
assumption always try to challenge your
ideas and do that faster the way the
longer you wait it's going to you're
going to get more invested in that idea
[Applause]
you